j'ouvre notre second débat tout de suite
il est vous le savez volontairement
décalé de l'actualité du jour et
consacrer aujourd'hui aux conséquences
du réchauffement climatique sur la
nature et notre santé premier constat
les fortes chaleurs la pollution font
bondir la mortalité les maladies
transmises par les animaux se développe
il y a un effet les et Samia de chia
tout ça que la paramètre dans les veines
qu'on a mais c'est pas grave c'est
douloureux ça va être difficile
depuis près de 20 ans Sandrine vit avec
la maladie de Lyme une simple morsure de
tique et sa vie bascule et je la arraché
de ma tête donc je l'ai vraiment pris
comme ça j'ai tiré ce qu'il faut jamais
faire et quand je l'ai sorti elle était
vraiment très grosse et très gorgée de
sang ça faisait longtemps qu'elle était
là en fait à cause d'un diagnostic
tardif l'infection s'installe et aucun
antibiotique ni traitement ne parvient à
la guérir alors le quotidien là c'est
des très grosses douleurs articulaires
j'ai vraiment du mal à marcher j'ai du
mal à me lever le matin c'est le cœur
c'est les insomnies et c'est la fatigue
et l'oeil là j'ai vraiment je supporte
pas la lumière comme Sandrine des
milliers de personnes sont mordus par
des tiques chaque année mais le nombre
d'infections à radicalement augmenté
elles ont plus que doublé en 10 ans on
sait que l'air de répartition des tiques
qui transmettent la maladie même donc
xodestre et sinus en fait son aire de
répartition augmente vers le nord et
également elle elle est présente à des
altitudes où on ne la retrouvait pas il
y a une vingtaine d'années de cela et ça
c'est certainement lié effectivement au
réchauffement climatique une
prolifération des tiques mais aussi une
apparition de nouvelles espèces de
tiques porteuses de nouvelles maladies
c'est yalluma marginatum et c'est
effectivement une tique qui va
transmettre des virus et en particulier
le virus de la fièvre de Crimée Congo
qui est un virus responsable de fièvre
hémorragique et donc très grave pour
l'homme les personnes qui sont atteintes
peuvent mourir de cette fièvre
hémorragique alors cette tique n'était
pas présente en France en fait on l'a
retrouvé mais de manière épisodique et
depuis une dizaine d'années elle s'est
établie en France donc elle est capable
de maintenir son cycle en France autre
animal porteur de maladies le moustique
tigre originaire d'Asie du Sud-Est il
est détecté pour la première fois en
métropole en 2004 et il y trouve un
climat compatible avec son développement
d'année en année il s'installe de plus
en plus au nord et avec lui des
pathologies jusqu'ici inconnues en
métropole comme la dengue en cette fin
d'année santé publique française alerte
ce que nous avons observé cette année
c'est que nous avons eu une augmentation
des cas à qui en France puisque donc au
total on en a eu 65 vous pourriez vous
dire 65 c'est pas grand chose c'est pas
beaucoup si c'est beaucoup parce que
jusqu'à présent le maximum c'était une
dizaine une dizaine de cas jusqu'en 2004
les autorités tentaient systématiquement
d'éradiquer l'insecte mais maintenant il
est là et on peut éventuellement jouer
sur sa ralentir sa progression mais on
s'en défera pas même constat pour le
réchauffement désormais assuré les
précipitations intenses et les
inondations gagnent en fréquence elles
aussi exposent à un risque accru de
maladie
des parasites ou des ou des bactéries
qui sont qui peuvent être transmis par
l'eau pourraient également émerger donc
c'est quand même quelque chose qu'on
surveille l'ensemble des répercussions
médicales du dérèglement climatique a
récemment poussé les plus grandes revues
scientifiques à s'unir et signer un
éditorial commun elle place le
réchauffement à hauteur de la plus
grande menace pour la santé publique
et c'est donc le thème de ce débat
j'accueille Anne Sénéquier bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes médecin co
directrice de l'Observatoire de la santé
mondiale à l'Iris Mary petenati bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes hydrogéologue au
bureau de recherche géologique et
minières Matthieu brun bonsoir bienvenue
directeur scientifique de la Fondation
farm fondation pour l'agriculture et la
ruralité dans le monde
éclaire Chartier évidemment est resté à
mes côtés comme toujours dans les pour
les chroniqueurs de cette émission qui
participe évidemment aux deux débats
peut-être une réaction à notre reportage
qui posait bien les enjeux qui a assez
c'est ce qu'on se disait je vais éclaire
tout le temps le regardant ce qui est
quand même assez effrayant il faut faire
la part des choses mais on parle de
maladies à transmission vectorielle
c'est ça alors c'est quoi transmission
vectorielle c'est 17% de la masse des
maladies infectieuses à travers le monde
et en fait c'est ça nécessite un vecteur
c'est-à-dire une transition entre la
maladie et l'être humain donc ça peut
être des moustiques comme on l'a vu des
tiques des punaises des puces et tout ce
petit monde qu'on n'aime pas trop voir
et vos choix d'exemple étaient bien
parce que du coup le moustique
effectivement bon on arrive plutôt de la
bande tropicale mais pas que et c'est
vrai que le live is qui est transporté
par la tique provient tout au long de la
défragmentation du couvert forestier
défragmentation des conversion
c'est-à-dire que la tique en
l'occurrence vit dans un écosystème
forestier ou elle a de quoi se nourrir
de de quoi aussi alimenter d'autres
d'autres espèces et finalement en
Amérique du Nord c'est aux alentours de
Boston comment on a commencé à avoir une
urbanisation
importante et on sait qu'aux États-Unis
c'est plutôt de l'étalement urbain on
est venu commencer à grignoter un petit
peu sur la forêt ce qui a amené des
animaux domestiques en contact avec ses
tics les tiques sont montés sur les
animaux domestiques sur l'humain et la
mondialisation et les flux de personnes
faisant le reste fait que on l'a vu
arriver en Europe de l'Est et descendre
progressivement sur le reste l'Europe de
l'Ouest donc ça c'est un phénomène
relativement je mets bien relativement
ancien mais si on fait le lien entre ces
donc c'est maladie à transmission
vectorielle et le réchauffement on l'a
vu un peu dans le reportage c'est
intéressant aussi parce que on parle
beaucoup du réchauffement climatique
mais ça nous donne aussi l'occasion de
parler de la deuxième phase de
l'activité humaine et c'est
effectivement la perte de la
biodiversité et le changement
d'utilisation des terres et tout ça
combiné plus le réchauffement climatique
qui va changer aussi les répartitions
géographiques de ces de ces vecteurs
parce que un moustique il est bien là où
il a la bonne température le bon degré
d'hygrométrie le changement climatique
va changer c'est répartitions
géographiques et du coup va ouvrir de
nouvelles possibilités et d'opportunités
à ces vecteurs pour venir un petit peu
plus dans le Nord par exemple quand on
parle du paludisme qui est avec
commencer par par un moustique en 2016
l'Europe a été déclarée exemple du
paludisme parce que ça a existé encore
sur le sud-est extrême de l'Europe il
est fort probable aujourd'hui alors que
le moustique à nos fèle donc porteur du
paludisme est déjà présent en France que
ça ne soit pas
une victoire sur le très long terme donc
cette maladie risque de réapparaître en
Europe c'est ce que vous c'est ce que
vous nous annoncez je voudrais qu'on
fasse chacun dans vos
spécialités respectives en quelque sorte
le constat de cette année de 2022 Marie
Pétain a-t-il et les vagues de chaleur
elles sont de plus en plus nombreuses
avec quelles conséquences notamment pour
la nature notamment pour les nappes
phréatiques alors les conséquences pour
les nappes phréatiques c'est qu'on
observe encore aujourd'hui un tiers des
niveaux des nappes qui sont bah voire
très bas sur le territoire donc on a eu
de la recharge dans le grand test qui
commence à se voir parce que là
normalement on est en pleine saison de
recharge des nappes mais là on voit on
observe des niveaux qui sont encore
vraiment bas
c'est une conséquence de cet hiver
dernier où la recherche s'est arrêtée un
peu plus tôt que d'habitude même voir
beaucoup plus tôt que d'habitude et on a
pas stocké suffisamment dans les nappes
donc on a observé cette cette année et
cet été des niveaux qui étaient vraiment
vraiment très bas on a cumulé cette
année une sécheresse météorologique une
sécheresse des sols une sécheresse
agricole et une sécheresse hydrologique
des débits dans les cours de hausse
faibles voire quasi inexistant des
niveaux de nappes très bas et ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que nos nappes
d'eau souterraines en été elle
soutiennent c'est débit de cours d'eau
donc elle soutiennent aussi la
biodiversité associée à ses cours d'eau
et alors c'est toujours la question
Corée c'est à dire que là on fait le
bilan d'une année mais est-ce qu'on est
dans une tendance lourde de
d'appauvrissement des nappes phréatiques
ou est-ce qu'il faut être prudent par
rapport à ça
alors en tant que scientifique on est
toujours prudent c'est bien c'est pour
ça qu'on vous invite
ce qu'on a vu c'est que depuis 2017 on a
une fréquence de plus en plus élevée des
périodes de sécheresse 2021 on a eu un
petit on a une période estivale qui
était plutôt humide mais cela n'a pas
suffi puisqu'on l'a vu cet été et c'est
dramatique vu que la recharge hivernale
c'est celle qui compte pour recharger
les stocks n'a pas eu lieu donc depuis
2017 en effet on observe une
augmentation de la fréquence de ces
sécheresses et c'est pas vous qui le dit
c'est le GIEC ces épisodes vont être de
plus en plus fréquents et de plus en
plus nombreux
des moustiques je viens vers vous dans
un instant mais des moustiques au mois
d'octobre aussi ça c'est ça
on l'a vécu et c'est pas normal quoi
c'est pas normal et on le voyait tout à
l'heure sur la petite animation c'est
vrai que les moustiques sont arrivés
donc par le sud de la France certains
sont remontés au dessus de des Alpes et
on commençait à coloniser l'ensemble du
territoire mais le problème c'est
qu'effectivement il a fait chaud très
chaud il a continué à faire chaud cette
automne mais il a plu et finalement dans
les jardins même sur les balcons ou même
les fenêtres dans les villes ça a amené
des des eaux stagnantes qui amènent un
une capacité pour le moustique de
nidifier et de pouvoir générer de
nouvelles générations et c'est vrai que
mi-octobre au début des vacances on se
faisait encore vraiment manger par les
moustiques les moustiques tigres donc et
d'ailleurs dans le 92 déjà 40% c'est
répertorié justement sur l'agence santé
de France c'est que 40% des communes
sont
infestées de de ce moustique et
aujourd'hui comme le disait dans le
reportage on ne cherche plus à
l'éradiquer parce qu'on ne pourra plus
aujourd'hui il est là pour rester parce
que ça lui convient et alors que nous
Homo sapiens nous avons 200 à 300 000
ans d'évolution ils ont 5 millions
d'années d'évolution derrière eux et du
coup ça leur permet d'être très
adaptable et on en rigole mais
aujourd'hui en Europe on a encore des
moustiques un peu similaires à ce qu'il
y a dans la bande tropicale avec des
cycles forestiers mais en Asie du
Sud-Est où on a une urbanisation très
importante on a les moustiques qui ont
des qui ont généré des des cycles de vie
urbains ou ils vont beaucoup plus vite
dans leur cycle de vie et on a des
générations de moustiques beaucoup plus
rapidement donc une population beaucoup
plus importante ce qui génère beaucoup
de problèmes Mathieu un bilan de cette
année 2022 les ou les agriculteurs
français enfin en tout cas c'est le
sentiment qu'on a eu là encore vous dire
c'est vrai ou pas ont été
particulièrement victimes de ces
bouleversements climatiques est-ce que
c'est est-ce que c'est confirmé on va
dire par les statistiques alors je serai
pas aussi prudent mais que c'est
vraiment confirmé par par les
statistiques au-delà de des dires de des
agriculteurs et des agriculteurrices
cette année 2022 c'est l'une des années
les plus chaudes qu'on n'est jamais
connues avec des sécheresses agricoles
très qui sont arrivés très tôt dans le
calendrier en début d'année
des changements énormes en termes de
rythme de phénologie donc des plans de
la manière dont les plantes se
développent on a pu voir des images de
la région Auvergne Rhône-Alpes toute
orange tel qu'on voudrait la voir en
automne alors que c'était fin août et
puis dans le même temps c'est ces
grandes sécheresses elles ont des
impacts extrêmement forts sur la culture
sur le calendrier des des cultures un
agriculteur une agricultrice quand il
décide de planter du blé du maïs il le
fait en prenant un énorme risque en
parrayant sur la météo à venir et puis
aussi en capitalisant sur ce qui s'est
passé ou ce qui ne s'est pas passé dans
les mois précédents on plante un
semis de blé on va attendre et puis le
moment où il va devoir se charger c'est
à dire construire ses épis le nombre
d'épis le nombre de graines dans les PIB
si ça arrive au mauvais moment s'il y a
en manque d'eau comme ça s'est passé
cette année on aura des épis de moins
bonne qualité avec moins de grains et
donc moins de rendement et en plus dans
un contexte de guerre à l'est de en
Europe de conflits au niveau mondial
c'est la sécurité alimentaire de
l'ensemble de la population qui se
retrouve largement menacée alors on va
essayer de ne pas être
inutilement anxiogène parce que ça l'est
déjà suffisamment dans ce débat et on va
essayer aussi de proposer des solutions
de voir comment finalement
l'humanité peut s'adapter mais je
voudrais quand même m'appuyer pour
rester sur la question de la santé le
lien entre réchauffement climatique
bouleversement climatique et santé
humaine sur cette étude de l'Université
d'Hawaï les chercheurs de cette
université ils ont ils ont scruté 375
pathologies d'infectieuses connues pour
avoir touché l'humanité et 10 aléas
climatiques et le résultat de cette
étude le plus frappant en tout cas c'est
ce chiffre que je vous donnais dans les
titres 58% des maladies infectieuses
sont susceptibles de s'aggraver à cause
du climat et ça fait dire à
camino Mora qui est professeur de
géographie auteur principal de cette
étude voilà sa citation il y a tout
simplement trop de une maladie et de
voix de transmission pour que nous
puissions penser pouvoir vraiment nous
adapter au changement climatique alors
je viens de dire on va essayer de pas
être trop anxiogène c'est mal parti
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire tiens si
je pose une question très concrète
est-ce que c'est l'émergence de
nouvelles maladies qu'il faut craindre
ou alors la diffusion plus large de
maladies existantes les deux parce que
encore une fois je reviens sur ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure c'est pas
seulement le changement climatique mais
tout ce qui émane de l'activité humaine
vis-à-vis de notre environnement et
c'est vrai que le changement
d'utilisation des terres enfin
malheureusement je pense que tout le
monde est au courant de ce qui s'est
passé en 2020 et ces maladies émergentes
telles que la covid 19 c'est pas la
première fois qu'on a en faire depuis
40 ans en fait on a une recrudescence de
ces maladies qui passent de l'animal à
l'homme du fait justement de cette
proximité on va dire mais finalement on
vit plus avec les animaux mais peut-être
que
que nous non personnellement mais
finalement avec les élevages intensifs
avec l'urbanisation qu'on évoquait tout
à l'heure ou dans les bidonvilles
finalement tout le monde a un cochon ou
une poule dans son arrière-cour on a une
densité humaine et animale dans un
espace très restreint l'augmentation de
l'agriculture intensive qui va pousser
justement dans les zones forestières va
amener la faune sauvage vers l'être
humain et finalement aujourd'hui on doit
s'inquiéter de ces deux pendant un les
maladies qui pour l'instant sont encore
cantonnées au monde animal mais
malheureusement on a un réservoir
très important qui est susceptible de
sauter la barrière de l'espèce et après
aujourd'hui une maladie émergente c'est
aussi la recrudescence d'une pathologie
que l'on connaît déjà mais qui va
arriver sur un autre territoire par
exemple line Dizzy c'était clairement
une maladie émergente en Europe parce
que ça n'était pas connu en Europe
précédemment donc il faut agir sur tous
les niveaux sur les causes du
réchauffement climatique mais aussi
justement sur cette sur cette
biodiversité sur notre rapport à
l'environnement aujourd'hui Matthieu
brun si on se concentre sur
l'agriculture est-ce qu'il y a des
animaux d'élevage de faire un petit
souffrent aussi de nouvelles maladies
liées à ce réchauffement ou à se
bouleversement climatique alors les
rapports du GIEC on vient montrer dans
le sixième rapport qui qui est en cours
de discussion mais qui a été publié ont
bien montré que le un des stress les
plus importants auxquels vont être
confrontés les animaux d'élevage ça va
être à la fois la sécheresse et
l'humidité quand on regarde les
différents scénarios on voit que ça va
être une des premières sources de stress
en plus des maladies des risques de
zones également donc on a on pense bien
sûr à nous les humains on pense parfois
aux plantes mais on pense pas
suffisamment aux animaux qui soient dans
les dans les dimensions pastorales en
Afrique de l'Ouest ou en Afrique
subsaharienne ou nos animaux d'élevage
les cadres dans le Sud-Ouest aussi de de
grippe et qui touchent tous les animaux
les volailles sont des exemples de plus
de ces stress auxquels ils vont être
soumis donc qui distressent pour trouver
de l'eau pour trouver des pâturages ou
pour lutter contre les maladies animales
qui émergent et qui peuvent des semer
des troupeaux bah engendre aussi des
risques de conflits sur les ressources
on le voit en Afrique subsaharienne on
le voit aussi bien sûr sur les nos
territoires européens l'eau est de plus
en plus rares ou en tout cas elle est à
des périodes de l'année de plus en plus
rare ce qui est
enclenche forcément des compétitions sur
l'accès à ces ressources et donc des
risques de tension parce
qu'effectivement et pas forcément plus
rare sur toute l'année quand on parle
vous allez vous allez peut-être nous
réexpliquer le cycle de l'eau je crois
que vous l'aviez déjà fait une fois sur
ce sur ce plateau mais c'est important
de le dire c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
peut-être la même quantité d'eau de
toute façon sur sur l'année mais à des
moments différents avec des intensités
différentes tout à fait alors vous
m'avez bien écouté la dernière fois
Thomas
c'est que avec le changement climatique
les précipitations oui ça va rester les
mêmes mais elles seront plus intenses
sur certaines parties du territoire et
voir quasi inexistante sur d'autres déjà
dans les variations saisonnières
effectivement il y a les périodes
hivernales où on a plus d'eau et les
périodes la période estivale où il y en
a moins et cette période estivale on va
cristalliser dessus justement parce que
c'est là où l'agriculture a le plus
besoin d'eau et puis que nous aussi
évidemment ce qu'on doit s'hydrater
comme les bêtes et donc
l'agriculture sur certains territoires
on va aussi les entre 50% voire 90% de
la consommation de la ressource en eau
assez
de l'année estivale et donc c'est pour
ça la consommation de toute l'année qui
est concentrée sur
ça passe surtout les territoires c'est
des territoires qui font plus
d'irrigations et sinon c'est environ 40
45 % et ça peut aller jusqu'à 70 jusqu'à
90 %. donc sur ces territoires c'est là
où c'est intéressant de parler de
l'échelle territoriale c'est-à-dire que
les solutions pour accéder à une
ressource en eau ou pour faire
évoluer les filières agricoles sur des
des cultures moins gourmandes en eau
c'est sur ces territoires qu'il faut
réfléchir à cette échelle pour avoir une
proposition de solutions avec vous parce
que je crois qu'Emmanuel Macron avait
lancé les les assises de l'eau c'était
au début de son premier quinquennat
[Musique]
quelques années donc il y a moyen de
faire un bilan est-ce que ça permet à la
France de mieux résister à ces épisodes
de sécheresse de mieux partager sa
ressource en eau alors ces assises de
l'eau elles ont constitué à faire
plusieurs groupes de travail et
notamment un groupe de travail sur les
solutions fondées sur la nature dans
lequel je faisais partie et donc à
l'issue des assises il y a eu un certain
nombre d'actions qui ont été proposées
et notamment donc de renforcer du usage
de ces solutions fondées sur la nature
pour retenir l'eau dans les territoires
également faire recours à la
réutilisation d'eau usées traitées pour
créer une ressource de substitution par
rapport à la ressource potable donc ça
ça avance ça avance doucement au niveau
de l'implémentation pourtant c'est c'est
l'intention qui compte ou c'est ou c'est
la mise en oeuvre mais je sais pas ce
que je dois dire c'est que suite à ces
assises il y a eu une le varen agricole
de l'eau et du changement climatique qui
s'est déroulée également et donc
d'ailleurs il y a eu une étape cet
après-midi enfin ce midi ou il y a eu un
point d'avancement concernant concernant
ces travaux donc l'idée c'est de pouvoir
augmenter implémenter de plus rapidement
le recours à cette réutilisation d'eau
usées de pouvoir
avoir une agriculture de conservation
des sols d'augmenter la transition des
filières pour
réduire la consommation en eau parce que
le premier de ce qui sort des assises ce
qui sort du varen c'est quand même la
première le premier adage c'est de
réduire sa consommation il y a le
premier plan écologique qui a été lancé
fin septembre par le ministre de
l'écologie et la ministre de la Santé
également et qui s'intéresse à la
gestion de l'eau et l'idée c'est d'ici
2025 c'est de réduire de 10% les
prélèvements en eau et de 25% d'ici 2035
donc il y a vraiment un effort qui doit
être fait au delà des solutions toutes
les solutions qu'on peut mettre en
oeuvre
sobriété sobrons de consommation alors
c'est un exemple intéressant et ça nous
ouvre la porte de d'une sorte de bilan
claire Chartier de
d'Emmanuel Macron et de et de l'écologie
que dire de son engagement la matière
alors entre Emmanuel Macron et
l’écologie vous l'avez sans doute
remarqué en effet Thomas c'est un
perpétuel rendez-vous manqué alors que
notre jeune président avait tout pour
comprendre l'ampleur du défi il ne fait
pas partie de la génération de ces
boomers biberonnés à l'abondance qui ont
tant de mal aujourd'hui à comprendre les
sacrifices exigées par le changement
climatique et pour regarder quand vous
parlez de vos meilleurs
et il n'avait pas trop mal commencé son
premier quinquennat en disant non à
l'aéroport de Notre-Dame-des-Landes non
Oméga programmes immobilier d'Europa
City en Île-de-France et non à la
montagne d'or ce vaste projet
d'exploitation minière en Guyane et puis
très vite la ligne verte d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est brouiller je parle de
couleur c'est parce que il y a eu la
crise des gilets jaunes déclenchés par
évidemment la taxe carbone ça n'a pas
aidé et ben non bien sûr et elle a mis
en évidence toute la difficulté pour un
politique de proposer des réponses aux
défis écologiques parce que à la
différence d'une association militante
un dirigeant politique et bien il est
confronté aux contradictions du réel et
puis il doit les surmonter ce qui donne
souvent des actions qu'on peut juger
imparfaite et on serait d'ailleurs assez
de mauvaise foi si l'on affirmait
qu'Emmanuel Macron ne fait rien sur le
front incendié de l'environnement il a
voulu une planification écologique qu'il
accélère les énergies renouvelables sauf
que tout cela ne suffit pas lever le
soupçon d'un président pas vraiment
passionné par la cause Emmanuel Macron
est structurellement écolo mais pas
culturellement confirme un ancien membre
de cabinet et il est frappant de voir
combien ce président qui aime tant les
symboles lorsqu'il veut nourrez la
France et sa mémoire et bien ils perd
tout inspiration lorsqu'il aborde la
thématique écologique il y a quelques
semaines empreinte time sur France 2 il
prend le sujet par le petit bout de la
lorgnette en insistant sur les voitures
électriques sans rien dire de
l'agriculture intensive ou de
l'effondrement de la biodiversité pour
un candidat qui assurait durant la
campagne que sa politique serait
écologique ou ne serait pas c'est un peu
court mais comment vous expliquer ce
manque de flamme et bien par son
positionnement politique je crois plus
que par des raisons psychologiques
positionnement qui le place dans une
situation inconfortable la ligne
d'Emmanuel Macron depuis 2017 consiste à
soutenir au maximum les entreprises pour
qu'elles développent l'activité rien de
plus logique et rien un très nouveau
monde non plus mais soutenir l'activité
pour l'instant cela signifie soutenir un
modèle encore fortement carboné donc
l'objectif d'Emmanuel Macron se marie
difficilement avec l'impératif
écologique qui remet lui très
profondément en question l'organisation
de toutes notre société on comprend dès
lors pourquoi le président miston sur le
progrès technologique parce que
l'innovation c'est la seule voie qui
permet de passer d'une croissance
classique à une croissance verte mais ce
faisant il se heurte aux militants
écologiques pour qui pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux le capitalisme Verdi
ou pas est incompatible avec la
préservation de la planète et si vous
ajoutez à cela le goût de la provocation
de notre président avec sa fameuse
phrase sur les Amish que le modèle
amiche permet de régler les défis de
l'écologie contemporaine
étonnant quand même de volontarisme sur
des sujets clés qui parlent à tout le
monde comme les passoires thermiques et
bien vous avez un président qui ne
parvient pas à convaincre Emmanuel
Macron joue la carte du raisonnable et
du moyen terme plutôt que celle de
l'empathie mais pourquoi pas les deux ce
serait beaucoup plus efficace pour
emmener toute la société vers la
révolution maire si claire effectivement
il faut il faut à la fois l'impulsion de
l'État il faut à la fois le les
entreprises il faut que la société
civile s'y mette parce que sinon on
voilà s'il y a seulement l'un des l'un
des leviers ça suffira pas je voudrais
qu'on fasse un focus sur le
l'agriculture Mathieu brin parce que on
le voit là on est déjà dans l'adaptation
parfois inquiétante il y a des solutions
qu'on commence à amorcer l'agriculture
c'est à la fois une des une des causes
du réchauffement on va pas on va pas se
voiler la face mais elle détient
forcément aussi une partie de la
solution ça va te plaire il y a une
triple relation qui est assez complexe
mais finalement plutôt plutôt simple
entre agriculture et changement
climatique l'agriculture est responsable
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
20% on va dire des émissions en France
un tiers si on prend le système
agroalimentaire dans son ensemble donc
une responsabilité en raison de
l'utilisation des intrants azotés par
exemple de du gasoil qu'on met dans dans
les tracteurs ou dans les dans les dans
les dans les outils de production bien
sûr du méthane avec les animaux mais
l'agriculture elle est aussi la première
des victimes enfin on doit tous besoin
de faire au moins trois fois par jour
quelque chose c'est de manger et de
boire bien entendu en tout cas c'est la
première des victimes les calendriers
culturaux sont vols en éclat les plans
vont arrêter de pousser à partir d'un
certain niveau de température et
troisième relation elle est aussi une
partie de la solution s'il y a bien un
secteur économique et absolument
formidable je dis pas ça parce que je
suis passionné par les questions
agricoles on peut quand même mais bon
mais c'est aussi le seul secteur qui
peut à la fois décarbonée tout en
assurant la souveraineté aliment de la
France boire de ce virage là on a
l'impression qu'il est il est pris mais
là aussi quoi il y a une question de de
d'accélérateur ou pas quoi il y a un
question de choc de temporalité
c'est-à-dire qu'on fait une course
contre la montre je prends un exemple
les semences qui font partie d'un un des
leviers qu'on peut activer pour
s'adapter au changement climatique et
atténuer aussi notre impact sur
l'environnement bah les semences pour
pour trouver une semence il faut entre 5
et 7 ans à peu près une semence qui va
résoudre un problème climatique un
problème de de pathologie sur une plante
donc ça veut dire Tarn-et-Garonne cet
été je mets beaucoup de sorgho par
exemple alors on peut aussi éventer des
ça vient d'Afrique ça cherchez des
nouvelles cultures peut-être il faudra
remplacer le blé par le mille le maïs
par le sorgho un sorgho c'est une plante
qui vient effectivement d'Afrique
d'Afrique subsaharienne qui a des
avantages parce que elle a un cycle de
culture qui résiste mieux à la chaleur
le maïs au-delà de 37 ou 38 degrés il
s'arrête de pousser sûrement il est très
très gourmand nous c'est peut aussi
consommer beaucoup mais le blé c'est la
même chose à partir d'un certain niveau
de chaleur au mois de mai ou juin la
plante devient stérile donc elle ne
produira rien nous quand on a chaud on
quitte les vêtements on boit de l'eau on
s'en sort comment on peut les plantes
elles sont démunies donc c'est vraiment
une course contre la montre pour
laquelle il faut mettre en œuvre tous
ces leviers on a parlé de l'innovation
variétale on a parlé de recherche il
faut essayer de voir aussi quels sont
les les conflits d'usage autour de la
technologie et d'innovation mais il y a
plein d'autres leviers qu'on peut
activer c'est ces nouvelles cultures
changer le calendrier aussi on récolte
le le grappes de raisin 15 jours plus
tôt mais on peut aussi parfois semer un
petit peu plus tôt dans l'année et puis
aller chercher de l'innovation au sud
dans la monterie à quelques temps à la
Fondation ferme sur lequel des
légumineuses les lentilles les pois
qu'on mange tous les jours mais en fait
les pois chiches qu'on fait pousser en
Egypte ou ou en Inde elles ont déjà des
capacités d'adaptation à ces sécheresses
c'est qu'on pourrait utiliser aussi en
franc donc ça demande de la coopération
Sud Nord c'est pas simplement le Nord
qui par le sud mais ça peut aussi
remonter ce partage d'innovation alors
puisque vous parliez d'Emmanuel Macron
ça me fait penser à la startup nation de
de ses premiers mois au pouvoir et donc
à la capacité de trouver des solutions
techniques est-ce que j'ai mis le génie
humain peut peut nous peut nous sauver
tiens par exemple on parle de nappe
phréatique ça ne peut être que naturel
je pose vraiment une question de B aussi
un pardon mais la recharge d'une nappe
phréatique ou alors est-ce que l'humain
peut intervenir pour faciliter une la
recharge de Naples peut intervenir pour
faciliter la recharge et il le fait déjà
dans de nombreux pays à l'international
on observe ça en Californie en injection
directe à partir d'eau usées traitées on
observe ça en Australie également et on
observe ça aussi en France uniquement
pour l'alimentation en eau potable je
m'explique et à partir des autres
surfaces c'est à dire qu'on soutient la
nappe aluviale d'accompagnement d'un
fleuve en la rechargeant à partir de ces
eaux du fleuve donc ça permet de stocker
une certaine quantité d'eau voilà qui
s'écoule moins vite que dans le fleuve
donc on retient l'eau sur le territoire
on crée des bassins de rétention
d'infiltration donc ça constitue parfois
dans des endroits des zones vertes aussi
ou on a une biodiversité aussi qui
s'installe pas sont des bassins
d'infiltration et aussi en réinfiltrant
cette ongle une barrière donc
hydraulique entre le fleuve et le chant
captant le chant captant sont les puits
qui fournissent l'eau potable et ça
permet d'éviter une contamination de ces
eaux stockées en nappe voilà pour une
éventuelle contamination des eaux du
fleuve donc on a les moyens techniques
il faut savoir que la ville de Lyon par
exemple utilise ce système de
réinfiltration c'est des centaines de
millions de mètres cubes qui sont
rechargés par an pour assurer une
alimentation en eau potable donc les
solutions techniques elles existent
elles sont peu implémentées en France
actuellement on va pas on va être sur
des chiffres d'une centaine de millions
de mètres cubes par an quelques
centaines de millions de mètres cubes
par an d'eau rechargés quand on voit les
30 et quelques milliards de mètres cubes
d'eau nécessaire voilà ce qu'on utilise
sur le territoire voilà on est loin de
gros volumes qui sont qui sont rechargés
dans les nappes alors je reste sur ce
thème qui vous est commun finalement de
de à la fois de la ressource en eau et
de l'évolution de notre agriculture avec
un témoignage je suis d'un
issu d'un reportage qui avait été
réalisé près de Montpellier par Jonathan
Dupriez il était parti à la rencontre
d'un viticulteur c'est vraiment une
illustration animale de ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure il est confronté
au réchauffement il cherche de nouveaux
cépages il est à la fois victime et
conscient que il est peut-être une
partie de la solution l'écoute le
viticulteur a aussi implanté de nouveaux
cépages comme le carignan ou le macabot
il résiste mieux aux fortes chaleurs si
l'agriculteur subit le réchauffement
climatique il est aussi en première
ligne pour agir on est au cœur de de du
du réchauffement climatique dans le sens
où on a l'impact mais on peut avoir
aussi une action alors certes notre
action sociale ne suffira pas mais
cumuler aux autres actions ça peut avoir
ça peut avoir un effet un effet positif
après ça ne reste que des gouttes d'eau
mais l'océan est formé de gouttes d'eau
message d'espoir l'océan est formé de
goutte d'eau le défi de ce viticulteur
ou des difficultés viticulteurs français
dans beaucoup de régions c'est quoi
c'est le degré d'alcool dans dans le vin
c'est ça on se retrouve avec des avec
des bouteilles avec des nouvelles dans
le rouge ou dans le blanc donc il faut
changer de cépage il faut trouver des
moyens de de s'adapter mais je trouve
que ce qu'il raconte est extrêmement
intéressant c'est parce que remplacer un
cépage par un autre maître du sorgho à
la place du maïs plus de légumineuses
etc c'est très bien mais il faut aussi
derrière qu'il y ait des filières qui
soient organisées dans la collecte dans
la distribution il faut qu'on ait des
semences c'est qu'on ait de la recherche
donc pardon c'est vraiment tout le temps
un semble dynamique qu'il faut surtout
pas voir l'adaptation aux gens
mathématiques comme un phénomène
statique c'est l'ensemble des acteurs
qui doivent ensemble travailler
collectivement et donc mais jusqu'à nous
jusqu'au consommateurs qui doivent être
aussi revoir la composition de son
assiette en diversifiant son assiette en
diversifie aussi le chant et donc
évidemment on stock du carbone en
changeant les types de culture
évidemment manger plus ou moins de
viande rouge notamment c'est un vrai
choix de consommateur avec des avec des
conséquences environnementales claires
c'est ce qu'on a perdu du temps avec ce
débat sur adaptation ou comment dire
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
il me semble qu'il y a eu un certain
moment certains qui disait si on se si
on pense adaptation ça veut dire que
d'une certaine manière on accepte les
dommages que l'on cause donc est-ce
qu'on a perdu du temps dans la mise en
place éventuellement de coopération et
de solutions comme ça active peut-être
perdu du temps mais surtout on a perdu
des moyens je voulais seulement une
course contre la montre qu'on est en
train de mener c'est un sprint et on est
plus sur du de la course de fond là
c'est c'est un sprint donc c'est une
question de d'utilisation des moyens
publics privés la recherche publique les
recherches privées moi je suis chercheur
donc forcément je pense dans mon dans
mon précaire de recherche mais qui
peuvent travailler ensemble à trouver ce
type de solutions qui soit adaptée à
l'adaptation c'est à dire le temps
change la météo change le climat change
mais qui permettent aussi d'atténuer
donc il faut vraiment faire ces deux
efforts en même temps une fois de plus
l'agriculture c'est un peu le le secteur
qui est gagnant gagnant vu depuis nos
latitudes privilégiées que sont l'Europe
on travaille beaucoup à la Fondation sur
les pays du Sud la donne est assez
différente alors on va on va terminer il
nous reste allé 9 10 minutes autour de
la question de la biodiversité je vais
revenir vers vous évidemment
Anne Senequier il y a des centaines de
milliers d'espèces animales et végétales
qui sont menacées de disparition par les
changements climatiques si vos
journalistes vous pouvez nous rejoindre
de nouveau puisque le mois prochain
Steve y aura un sommet sur la
biodiversité à Montréal
bon ça commence pas bien vraiment parler
d'un enthous me débordant c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire Thomas aucun chef
d'État ou de gouvernement ne participera
à la conférence bio diversité de l'ONU
elle a été maintes fois reportée à cette
conférence elle devait avoir lieu en
Chine en 2020 mais le covid a eu raison
d'elle elle sera finalement organisée
donc du 7 au 19 décembre prochain ce
sera à Montréal la Coop 15 c'est un peu
l'équivalent de l'accord de Paris sur le
climat au total 195 pays plus l'Union
européenne vont tenter et bien de
définir un cadre mondial pour la
préservation de la biodiversité jusqu'en
2030 à noter que les États-Unis n'y
participeront pas alors forcément ça
limite un peu les ambitions que peut-on
attendre de ce sommet pour l'instant 22
ou 22 objectifs ont été fixés parmi eux
le placement sous protection de 30% de
terre et des terres et des mers la
réduction des pollutions ou encore la
restauration des espaces naturels voilà
pour les objectifs généraux mais les
négociations se poursuivent actuellement
écoutez Sylvie lemait elle est
ambassadrice déléguée à l'environnement
c'est elle qui est chargée des
discussions pour la France et pour
l'instant et ben c'est pas gagné
le climat ne doit pas prendre la main
sur le vivant et il faut respecter cet
équilibre pour réussir la mission qui
nous incombe à tous chacun dans nos
différentes fonctions de freiner cette
horion de biodiversité mais surtout
survie de l'humanité une végétation type
Sud-Ouest en plein Paris c'est ce vers
quoi on se dirige d'ici 2100 selon les
scientifiques auditionnellement merci
Steve pour tous ces détails Anne siniki
vous l'avez un peu évoqué tout à l'heure
mais je pense que c'est très intéressant
d'entrer dans le détail c'est à
pauvrissement de la biodiversité ça a
des conséquences sur notre santé c'est
ce que vous disiez ça ça quoi ça
rapproche certains animaux des zones où
vivent les humains déjà il y a cette
logique là quoi oui en fait c'est
multidimensionnelles il y a un concept
qui s'appelle le one hell c'est à dire
une santé qui va intriquer
l'environnement la santé animale et la
santé humaine et du coup le concept
wannel dit que si on veut travailler sur
la il faut travailler sur sur ces trois
thématiques et concrètement en quoi
notre survie dépend de la survie des
autres espèces tout simplement par
exemple la survie du ton obèse dépend
ton baise et ce poisson qui est le plus
pêché dans les dans les océans
actuellement ou finalement il n'y a
aucune législation parce que c'est dans
la haute mer et on a vu au mois d'août
déjà que ils avaient raté le coche pour
justement
se mettre d'accord là-dessus et
finalement se tomber il est dans une
chaîne de une chaîne alimentaire comme
comme
tous les autres animaux sur terre et
finalement à partir du moment où il
manque un maillon ça va se répercuter
sur tous les éléments de sous et tous
les aimants en bas en fait il y a le
phytoplancton et l'océan et le premier
producteur d'oxygène sur Terre on parle
souvent de la l'Amazonie c'est vrai mais
le vrai véritable poumon de la terre
si on a plus ces petits éléments là qui
font l'oxygène de l'océan mais du coup
on va avoir un véritable problème
d'autre part ça c'est le microbiome
marin si je ne me trompe absolument mais
par exemple si on repart aussi sur les
terres si nous manque des abeilles on va
avoir un problème agricole et on aura
une problématique de sécurité
alimentaire et effectivement oui c'est
rapprochement entre les zones les
excusez-moi la faune sauvage et l'être
humain va générer justement cette
opportunité de saut d'espèce donc en
fait on est impacté par plusieurs
plusieurs directions et je pense qu'ils
aient important de ne pas réfléchir de
manière verticale et c'est vrai et c'est
je suis complètement d'accord à ce qui
vient d'être dit le changement
d'utilisation des terres le rapport à
l'environnement la perte de biodiversité
est complètement éclipsée par le
changement climatique et par grande
thématique comme de la même manière que
vous disiez tout à l'heure ou finalement
le changement climatique dans sa
globalité
éclipser par le débat sur la voiture
électrique et où on voit que ça et
finalement on voit pas tout ce qu'il y a
à côté donc c'est vrai que la
transversalité est vraiment primordiale
et aujourd'hui vous parliez de que
j'étais finalement inquiétante et c'est
vrai que finalement l'objectif est pas
d'être inquiétant mais pour résoudre un
problème il faut avoir un énoncé clair
je pense que c'est important finalement
d'avoir tous les déterminants pour que
la solution on voit bien que c'est très
compliqué de générer une solution au
niveau international parce qu'on a
besoin de coopération et de coordination
il faut que si on arrive à trouver une
solution elle puisse répondre
véritablement à tous les déterminants et
pas à retrouver une solution pathogène
qui va nous apporter une solution à un
problème la voiture électrique répond
aux problèmes de la concentration de CO2
en ville mais elle est loin de répondre
à toutes les problématiques de la
voiture en ville tiens je vais terminer
avec cette proposition cette annonce
d'Emmanuel Macron font planter un
milliard d'arbre que vous entendez ça
vous vous dites super c'est très bien ou
alors ces petits buzoie et puis après
vous dites gadget ou alors d'accord mais
quelles essences d'arbres enfin il y a
toutes les questions qui viennent avec
quoi voilà c'est un peu le l'inverse du
choc de simplification planter un
milliard d'arbre oui mais où quand
comment avec qui pourquoi et surtout
qu'est-ce qu'on crée comme valeur autour
des écosystèmes planter un milliard
d'arbre d'une monoculture intensive ça a
pas beaucoup de sens par contre
travailler sur la construction de cette
fameuse muraille verte en Afrique
subsaharienne qui permettrait de stopper
l'érosion des sols à désertification
voilà un autre enjeu dont on parle assez
peu les seuls il y a le climat il y a la
diversité il y a bien sûr les sols aussi
qui sont un élément extrêmement
important donc on peut se réjouir de la
mobilisation générale c'est un mot qu'on
aime beaucoup chez nous la Fondation
cette mobilisation générale autour des
écosystèmes autour de l'agriculture et
de l'environnement mais comme toujours
en fait il faut aller dans le détail il
faut se laisser l'opportunité de bien
comprendre quelle valeur on va créer
autour de ces écosystèmes forestiers
toujours est-il qu'un seul nu c'est un
seul qui va assez rôder beaucoup plus
vite qui va être peut-être être perdre
aussi de sa biodiversité perte de ses
qualités et donc ça va jusqu'à la
pratique agricole de couvrir ses sols
quand ils sont nus jusqu'à mettre des
arbres là où ils ont été déforestés
auparavant et si on reste sur la
responsabilité ou les solutions parce
qu'on a essayé quand même dans ce débat
d'amorcer comme ça quelques pistes de
solutions sur la biodiversité là aussi
il y a une part de responsabilité de
l'agriculture dans la pauvrissement mais
la capacité à recréer de la biodiversité
dans les cultures c'est quoi c'est les
haies par exemple qu'on replante c'est
des absolument ça semble
ultra simple sauf que l'effet est réel
les faits réels en fait on a des moyens
de revenir rapidement sur des tendances
qui ont été mises en mise en route à
condition d'investissement à condition
de création de filière et
d'accompagnement des acteurs de la forêt
ou de l'agriculture le bon exemple c'est
la culture de conservation des sols vous
en parliez tout à l'heure ça veut dire
changer nos techniques agricoles pour
stocker plus de carbone et initiative
internationale s'appelle les quatre pour
1000 si on augmente la
de carbone dans les sols on permet on
peut quasiment annuler les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre donc ça c'est
formidable et ça repose sur un principe
très simple la photosynthèse ça
représente ça repose pas sur une
innovation technologique formidable une
batterie ça repose sur l'activité
naturelle des plantes donc c'est
extraordinaire la nature et
l'agriculture merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat et je
vous dis à bientôt sur public Sénas je
me souviens du cycle de l'eau là
maintenant c'est pour les c'est pour
l'éternité c'est grâce à vous je vous
dis évidemment à demain pour un nouveau
numéro de sens public et puis votre
prochain rendez-vous politique sur notre
antenne la matinale bonjour chez vous
Oriane Mancini vous le voyez reçoit
Olivier Faure le premier secrétaire du
Parti socialiste belle soirée à toutes
et à tous